(intense music)
- Holy
- Welcome to episode three
of Buzzfeed's, Running Out of Ideas.
Yes, it's still the same day.
What we've done is took popular key words
and put them on some dice.
Then we roll those dice
and whatever combination
of words it lands on is
the title of our video.
So let's get to it for a third time.
(door opens)
Okay, so I'm here with the team.
We're ready to roll the dice
and find ourselves a video.
Go!
(die clank)
Alright!
- There we go
- [Jordan] Whooo!
- Yeah, terrifying.
- Terrifying.
Lip.
(dice knocks)
Makeup.
DIY.
I love that!
- Yeah!
- Okay, I'm gonna write
this up on the board.
So I feel like we can't
just do a hundred layers
- [Woman] No.
- because it's overdone now.
- I have an idea.
(hand hits table)
Why don't we just put lipstick
everywhere on our face?
- I feel like there's a different route
we can go other than just
painting our whole face.
- Flesh lips?
- What?!
- So that it just looks
like you have no lips.
- I like that idea though.
- [Woman] Flesh lips.
- [Man] Yeah,
like DIY flesh lips.
So it looks like there's
no lips there, yeah.
- Flesh lips, great, great.
- Yeah, I like it.
(pulsating techno music)
- Well, the day has come.
It is time for, Terrifying DIY Lip Makeup.
So I'm here with, Emily
and we're going to make it
look like I have no lips,
I guess?
(girl laughs)
- [Girl] You're fine with just breathing
out of your nose, right?
- Sure, great.
(girl laughs)
(blows raspberry)
- You're gonna look
like Beaker from the Muppets.
- I'm gonna look like a Simpson.
I'm gonna have to stop
talking soon, aren't I?
- Well yeah, I'm just gonna
put on modeling wax now.
(Jordan laughs)
- If you laugh.
- I can't laugh either!
- Yeah.
- Just keep molding it until
I get this smooth surface.
(man laughs)
- That looks so weird.
Now that I'm looking at it,
I'm kind of like, "oh."
Maybe this was a bad choice! (laughs)
- [Girl] It's fine, Jordan.
(both laugh)
- Alright.
(girl laughs)
- Okay!
No lip surprise time!
(laughter)
Alright!
- Let's bring her around.
She's a trooper.
- What's wrong with your lips though?
How is Jordan always the one
who has to suffer through everything?
- You look great, Jordan.
- Woah!
Woah!
(man laughs)
- What is that?
- [Jordan] Mmhmm
- Woah, you're kind of scary.
(everyone groans)
(laughter)
- [Girl] Wait, what?
- I'm sorry, I can't
look at you right now.
- Oh my God!
(laughter)
- I don't trust her!
- Jordan, no!
(laughs)
- Oh my God!
- Okay, I really wanna
be done with this now.
So we're gonna go take it off.
It's terrible.
Okay, well.
Terrifying DIY Lip Makeup.
It's a video.
You know the second you can't
have something, you want it?
- [Girl] Yeah.
- The second I couldn't talk,
I just had all these things to say.